[Musique]
quand je suis tombé je suis un peu rien
j'ai chanté un peu mes jambes mes bras
je la seule chose que je chantais c'est
les larmes que les gens bijoux
les wax sont des vapoteuses à cannabis
c'est illégal au Québec mais vous en
trouverez couramment dans les écoles
secondaires on ne suivit la piste de
ceux qui font de l'argent avec ce
produit qui fait des ravages chez les
jeunes
[Musique]
moi quand j'ai
eu peur de me réveiller avec des
séquelles à vie
je m'en veux tellement d'avoir pris ça
[Musique]
concentré ok est-ce qu'on sait c'est que
les risques qu'on parle depuis tantôt
sont beaucoup plus élevés quand on parle
d'un concentré comme la wax la wax un
mot sur toutes les lèvres dans les
écoles secondaires du Québec wax pour
wax Pen une vapoteuse à concentré de
cannabis c'est la nouvelle façon de
consommer depuis 15 ans j'en ai vu des
problématiques mais qui prennent de
l'ampleur à cette vitesse là
non
qu'est-ce que identique au vapoteuse à
nicotine les Wacken sont ultra simple
d'utilisation des jeunes comme Simon 18
ans l'ont vide compris ce n'est pas son
vrai nom il a accepté le témoigner de
façon anonyme de sa consommation
c'était beaucoup plus simple à fumer on
n'avait pas besoin de rouler c'était tu
le tu le mets dans ta bouche tu as
spires puis c'est correct tu es beaucoup
plus défoncé que quand on fumait un
joint comme d'habitude
généralement de 68 à 86 % de THC c'est
des taux qui sont anormalement élevés
ces concentration rendent les wax
illégaux Québec mais pas dans les autres
provinces canadiennes où on peut les
trouver dans un emballage neutre
mais ce qui circule dans les écoles du
Québec c'est tout autre chose les wax
Pen viennent dans des petites boîtes
colorées des saveurs de fruits des
personnages alors que la loi fédérale
interdit les emballages attrayants pour
les jeunes la loi provinciale elle
interdite camoufler le goût et l'odeur
du cannabis
si bien que les jeunes en consomme à
l'école dans les toilettes les corridors
même carrément dans leur classe
on était en français
[Musique]
une expérience qu'elle n'oubliera jamais
pour se cacher d'une personne
responsable entrée dans la classe et la
retenue son souffle après avoir aspiré
une seule bouffée de Wax
[Musique]
j'ai coupé mon souffle ma santé je suis
tombé quand je suis tombé je suis un peu
plus rien j'ai chanté un peu mes jambes
mes bras je la seule chose que je
chantais c'est les larmes couler dans
mes yeux son bijou j'ai peur de rester
handicapé
Simon à lui aussi subit les contrecoups
des wax
[Musique]
cannabyloïde fait que ça dans le fond
c'est quand trop de THC dans ton corps
c'est comme une gastro où je vomissais
pendant une dizaine de jours sans arrêt
je perd une quinzaine de livres aussi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sont malheureusement
n'est pas isolé le phénomène s'étend à
l'échelle de la province moi je vous
dirais que le en 22 23 là c'est
ça l'expose
à toutes les semaines il y a un
événement qui va arriver en lien avec ça
qui consomment régulièrement ou externe
mais là je pense qu'on a un problème de
consommation le cannabis est beaucoup
moins haut le western c'est beaucoup
plus accessible
c'est sûr que si je vais sur Instagram
aujourd'hui je peux acheter des wax
paint dans la même journée
très jeune consommateur accepter qu'on
le suive pendant qu'il testait les
différentes façons d'en acheter
un message avant les jeunes devaient
connaître un vendeur pour acheter du
cannabis aujourd'hui pour les wax Pen ça
se passe sur les réseaux sociaux comme
Instagram ou snapchat il répondit
on peut aussi en commander directement
sur internet à des boutiques en ligne
qui ont l'air légitime ou sur le site de
la marque désirée il existe même des
sites qui offrent la livraison à
domicile
[Musique]
une pizza
salut
[Musique]
mais les jeunes peuvent aussi se tourner
vers une quatrième option
moi j'ai plusieurs jeunes qui nomment se
déplacer à OK
l'endroit dans cette intervenant parle
c'est le territoire de Cannes sataki
voisin de la ville d'Oka nous nous y
sommes rendus avec notre consommateur
[Musique]
de magasins opèrent librement sans
suivre la loi québécoise
souvenez-vous au Québec l'âge légal pour
acheter des produits du cannabis et de
21 ans
pour le 20 c'est ce que tu as ici sur le
comptoir
en tout Simon a pu entrer et acheter des
wax Penn dans 3 magasins sans problème
mon quartier à aucun endroit puis ils
nous ont même donné des petits cadeaux
des petits cadeaux mais premièrement il
y a une carte de points
OK puis à chaque fois
[Musique]
qu'un des commerces qui ont vendu des
wagen n'a voulu nous accorder d'entrevue
nous avons posé la question au grand
chef de cane Satake
[Musique]
peu importe ce qui vendent maintenant
sur ce territoire l'argument pour
pouvoir vendre du cannabis se résume à
une chose l'activité serait protégée par
un droit ancestral si quelqu'un qui vend
du cannabis ou qui est en possession
produit illégal de cannabis prétend
défendre un droit les tribunaux
canadiens nous apprennent que c'est
possible il faut en faire la
démonstration cette démonstration n'a
pas encore été faite mais pour mettre
Nadir André lui-même autochtone
l'explication est plus politique que
légale pour l'instant il semble qu'il y
a une paix sociale et que il semble pas
avoir un besoin
nécessairement de s'adresser au tribunal
pour régler cette question particulière
autrement dit il y a un flou autrement
dit il y a un flou à Canet s'attaquer
particulièrement après la crise d'aucun
ce flou fait en sorte que les policiers
n'osent plus intervenir
se trouve à 6 km d'ici mais ça leur
prend trois heures pour répondre à un
appel et comme il n'y a plus de corps
policiers autochtones à Cannes
s'attaquer toutes les conditions sont
réunies pour que la porte soit grande
ouverte à des individus indésirables
quand les personnes savent que la police
qui est supposée d'appliquer la même loi
sur tout le territoire n'intervient pas
évidemment qu'il y a des gens qui se
servent de cette opportunité là pour
faire du commerce certains magasins font
preuve d'une grande diligence ils sont
là pour les bonnes raisons mais d'autres
peut-être pas
il y a des individus criminalisés qui
ont le contrôle
qui détruisent notre communauté en
faisant du profit et qui commettent ces
crimes là
[Musique]
après la pause une chance que notre
équipe ne pas essayer les wax pent parce
que les producteurs font tout pour les
mélanger
[Musique]
à peu près tous les jeunes savent
comment trouver ces vapoteuses à
cannabis les wax Pen mais pour prouver
ce qui les fabrique ça c'est plus
compliqué
nous faisons nos valises direction
l'Ontario objectif tenter de comprendre
d'où viennent les deux marques les plus
populaires dans les écoles du Québec
Jason Factory et gas Gang
[Musique]
et nous recherchent nous conduisent dans
la grande région de Hamilton
[Musique]
toutes les compagnies ou les individus
qui sont liés à ces compagnies-là ont
des adresses dans la région où on s'en
va la première compagnie gas gang a une
adresse à oswegun au cœur du territoire
autochtone de six nations
[Musique]
sur place pas un chat ou presque il y a
clairement
il y a bien des signes de vie
mais on est loin d'une installation
industrielle sans se mettre en marché
une quarantaine de saveurs de Wax Pen
à quelques pas de là on entre dans un
des nombreux magasins de cannabis de
is
étonnant car en ligne la marque semble
bien vivante
nous nous mettons donc sur la piste de
grisol sur papier dreason Factory a
l'air d'une simple compagnie qui n'a pas
une longue histoire mais en fouillant
les adresses et les non inscrits c'est
tout un organigramme corporatif qui se
révèle et tout gravit autour de son
fondateur
changement d'adresse sans commenter
spécifiquement les cas de griezel
Factory et de Gas gang se spécialiste de
la GRC a déjà vu ce type de structure
corporatives dans ses propres enquêtes
ce serait une signature du crime
organisé certains que au niveau de ce
type d'enquête là les acteurs du crime
organisé on l'a vu dans la part de
passer que camoufler derrière des
entreprises réalistes enregistrés de
façon conforme pour justement donner un
apparence légitime à la compagnie
prochain de la ville de Simco ou Lambo a
fondé Factory en 2021
à cette même adresse deux ans plus tôt
il a aussi fondé Simco Botanica qui
s'affiche comme un producteur agricole
[Musique]
l'employé sur place appelle celui que
nous cherchons lui mentionne que nous
nous intéressons à la compagnie Jason
Factory
ne se trouve pas dans la liste des
compagnies qui ont une licence fédérale
pour la production cannabis pourtant il
y a une énorme serre sur le terrain
individu discret au passé trouble en
2012 Lambo a purgé une peine de 9 mois
avec sursis pour utilisation frauduleuse
d'électricité et production et
possession illégales de marijuana en vue
d'en faire le trafic
[Musique]
on peut produire du cannabis si on a une
prescription d'en consommer pour traiter
une condition médicale mais ça ne donne
pas le droit d'en produire dans le but
d'en vendre
les certificats d'inscription pour des
productions personnelles à des fins
médicales pour légitimer leur production
illicite
[Musique]
le parcours corporatif de Jason Factory
et pour le moins sinueux Lambo a été aux
commandes de sa compagnie pendant une
seule journée dès le lendemain de sa
création en 2021 griezel Factory
changera d'administrateur changera
ensuite d'adresse vendra la propriété
qui se trouve à l'adresse du siège
social mais conservera l'adresse
d'affaires puis changera de nom pour
Outlook expoxy tout ça en seulement un
an
vous êtes perdus c'est exactement ça le
but
sur le terrain le caporal Paradis a
aussi vu des manœuvres similaires
c'est vraiment
pour brouiller les pistes policières au
niveau des enquêtes
[Musique]
prochaine arrêt l'adresse que grand
Lambo a utilisé pour identifier sa
résidence personnelle à Hamilton
[Musique]
pendant que nous prenons quelques images
de la propriété la fiancée sort notre
présence dérange
someone
elle nous demande de quitter mais un
détail nous chicote
nous retrouvons sa page LinkedIn
il s'affiche comme un employé de Simco
Botan pas de préciser que c'est une
compagnie de production de cannabis
quelques minutes plus tard cet employé
fera disparaître de ses réseaux sociaux
tout ce qui le lie à cinco botanicos et
à grand Lambo
à quelques parties de maisons de là
toujours à Milton se trouve aussi
l'adresse de Diane toutan celui qui a
enregistré l'autre compagnie de Wax Pen
qui nous intéresse gaz
[Musique]
des documents sont non démontent
pourtant clairement que gas gang est une
compagnie de produits de concentrés et
de cannabis
[Musique]
il a peut-être une prescription mais
trois fois au cours des trois dernières
années Gian tuttown a non seulement été
accusé de possession de cannabis et de
cocaïne en vue d'en faire le trafic mais
aussi d'argent provenant de la
criminalité des accusations qui sont
tombées
[Musique]
alors résumons il fait face à des
accusations de trafic de stupéfiants
dont il est finalement blanchi il crée
une compagnie qui produit des
stupéfiants et il finit par s'en
départir mais il maintient ne rien
connaître de cette industrie
[Musique]
et devinez quoi l'adresse d'affaires de
l'acheteur every porter nous ramène à la
case départ
oswigun sur le territoire autochtone de
six nations
sur place toujours personne est-ce que
l'objectif de cette transaction était de
profiter du flux juridique autour des
réserves autochtones
difficile de le vérifier mais cette
adresse a certainement d'autres utilités
elle sert aussi pour une autre
entreprise au nom d'Eren porter celle-ci
d'importation
c'est à travers elle que nous trouvons
enfin son numéro de téléphone
après cet appel
Erin porter n'a pas voulu élaborer
davantage Greenland beau lui n'a pas
voulu répondre à nos questions sur
grezos Factory s'il ne semble pas trop
importuné par les questions d'une
journaliste c'est peut-être parce qu'ils
savent qu'ils sont loin d'être la
priorité des autorités policières
bonjour tout le monde
après le témoignage dans un comité
sénatorial d'un des policiers de six
nations on est juste trois policiers
dans notre unité antidrogue et on
consacre la majeure partie de notre
temps au trafic du Fontanel alors on a
rarement le temps de nous occuper des
questions relatives à la loi sur le
cannabis
[Musique]
parmi les 635 communautés autochtones du
Canada seul une dizaine tolère le
commerce du cannabis
souvent parce qu'elle craignent
l'infiltration du crime organisé
certaines l’interdisent ou le règlemente
c'est la voie que veut emprunter le
grand chef de Cannes sataki
c'est un de mes objectifs avant la fin
de mon mandat de mettre en place une
réglementation
[Musique]
ni la Sûreté du Québec ni le ministère
de la Sécurité publique ni même le
ministère de la santé n'ont voulu nous
accorder d'entrevue à la caméra pour ce
reportage
[Musique]
d'autres conseils ils l'ont essayé avant
moi mais rien
le ministre responsable des relations
avec les Premières nations reconnaît la
présence du crime organisé dans
certaines communautés autochtones
de moteurs criminés vont agir dans des
lieux de grande vulnérabilité est-ce que
les présentements dans les communautés
sont utilisés par le crime organisé pour
faire le ventre de stupéfiants les
réponses si oui est-ce que c'est une
priorité pour nous la réponse si oui
ferme les yeux vu la complexité de la
situation oui vous pourriez même
utiliser l'expression les yeux grands
fermés parce qu'ils savent ce qui se
passe ici mais refusent d'agir le
ministre reconnaît que le gouvernement
ne va pas assez vite je vais accepter de
prendre une partie du blanc pour la
vitesse et je continue de dire qu'une
solution rapide n'arrivera pas
et pendant que les autorités tergiverse
les wax Pen eux continuent de séduire
les jeunes pour toi est-ce que c'est
définitivement terminé ou non j'en ai
commandé un qui arrive demain
[Musique]